[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halallweg
ungewöhnliche Uhrzeit für uns schön dass
Sie dabei sind guten Abend den
überraschendsten Abschied des Tages hat
Norbert lemann ja Jürgen Klopp beendet
zum Saisonende seinen Trainerjob in
Liverpool guten Abend außerdem haben wir
diese Themen für Sie
mehr Schutz für die Zivilbevölkerung der
Internationale Gerichtshof fordert
Israel auf alles zu tun um einen
Völkermord in Gaza zu
verhindern die Wut französischer Bauern
tausende Landwirte protestieren in
unserem Nachbarland gegen die Regierung
und legen dabei mehrere Autobahnen
lahm und klar geführt und doch verloren
Alexander SRE verpasst knapp den Einzug
ins Finale der Australian Open
[Musik]
vor knapp vier Wochen hatte Südafrika
Israel vor dem höchsten un-gericht wegen
Völkermordes im Gazastreifen verklagt
heute gab es eine erste Stellungnahme
des Gerichts es sieht eine Gefahr von
Völkermord verlangt aber keinen
sofortigen Waffenstillstand sondern
fordert Israel auf die Zivilbevölkerung
besser zu
schützen der Internationale Gerichtshof
in Den Haag ist zuständig weil beide
Staaten die Völkermord vention
unterzeichnet haben entsprechend sind
sie verpflichtet den Entscheidungen der
Richter zu folgen durchsetzen kann das
Gericht diese allerdings nicht was das
für den Krieg im Gazastreifen bedeutet
Florian
Neuhann es wirkt beinah wie eine
Sportübertragung Public Viewing in den
Hag vor dem Internationalen Gerichtshof
da zeigen Sie auf einer Leinwand wie die
Vorsitzende des un-gerichts über die
Gefahr eines Völkermords im Gazastreifen
spricht Gericht ist sich sehr bewusst
über das Ausmaß der Tragödie die sich in
der Region abspielt und ist zutiefst
beunruhigt über den andauernden Verlust
von Leben und menschliches
Leiden Israel so das Gericht müsse alles
dafür tun das Leben der Palästinenser zu
schützen und es müsse dringend mehr
humanitäre Hilfe zu lassen geklagt hatte
die Regierung Südafrikas deren Forderung
nach einem sofortigen Waffenstillstand
aber folgt das Gericht heute nicht
Israel wird ja weiterhin angegriff
und befindet sich in der Ausübung seines
Rechts auf Selbstverteidigung das im
Völkerrecht als ein naturgegebenes recht
angesehen wird die Entscheidung ist
gerade verkündet da beginnt der Kampf um
Deutungshoheit in den HA legt die
südafrikanische Außenministerin den
Beschluss als Erfolg
aus um diese Anordnung umzusetzen
bräuchte es einen Waffenstillstand ohne
kann die Anordnung doch nicht
funktionieren dagegen Israel den Vorwurf
des Völkermords der Premier betont per
Videobotschaft Israels Respekt für das
internationale Recht ist
unerschütterlich genauso wie unsere
heilige Verpflichtung unser Land unser
Volk zu
verteidigen ob im Gazastreifen ein
Völkermord begangen wird dazu äußerte
sich das Gericht heute noch nicht das
Verfahren könnte Jahre
dauern holen wir unseren Korrespondenten
in telaviv dazu Michael beerunge wie
wird die Entscheidung in Israel
aufgenommen ja hier überwiegt ganz klar
Erleichterung und auch Genugtung darüber
dass der Gerichtshof nicht den
sofortigen stopf der Kampfhandlungen
angeordnet hat und damit ja in gewisser
Weise anerkennt das Recht Israels auf
Selbstverteidigung der Vorwurf dass
Israel aber trotzdem Kriegsverbrechen im
Sinne der
völkermordkonvention begangen haben
könnte der wird mit großer Empörung
zurückgewiegen zurückgewiesen gleich
wohl ist da natürlich die Sorge dass die
internationale Position in diesem
Konflikt der noch lange andauern wird
deutlich geschwächt werden könnte
premier Netanyahu hat gesagt dass er
nach wie vor alles tun werde um die
Zivilbevölkerung zu schützen nach wie
vor versuchen würde mehr humanitäre
Hilfslieferung nach gasaza reinzulassen
aber das davor das ist nicht gelungen
das weiß die Regierung auch netanah hat
ist selbst eingestanden dass es nicht
gelungen ist die Zivilbevölkerung
ausreichend zu schützen und so wird nun
die internationale Gemeinschaft sehr
genau darauf schauen den nächsten Wochen
in welcherweise Israel seine
Kriegsführung bereit ist zu ändern
Michael bewerunge live aus Tel Aviv
vielen
Dank mehrere Mitarbeiter des UNO
Hilfswerks für palästinensische
Flüchtlinge stehen im Verdacht in den
Terrorangriff der Hamas auf Israel
verwickelt gewesen zu sein jetzt wurden
sie entlassen eine Untersuchung soll
folgen Israel hatte der UNO-Organisation
Informationen über die Mitarbeiter
übermittelt die US-Regierung hat ihre
Unterstützung für das Hilfswerk deshalb
zunächst
eingestellt nach Deutschland in mehreren
Städten sind wieder Menschen gegen
Rechtsextremismus auf die Straße
gegangen Sowi hier in sabrücken dazu
aufgerufen hatte ein Bündnis
verschiedener Gruppen und Gewerkschaften
um gegen eine AFD Veranstaltung zu
demonstrieren Auslöser der bundesweiten
Proteste war das bekanntwererden ein es
Treffens von Rechtsextremisten an dem
auch AFD und CDU Mitglieder teilgenommen
hatten der Landtag von Thüringen hat
heute der Opfer des Holocausts gedacht
in einer Zeit in der Antisemitismus auch
in Deutschland wieder zunimmt
Parlamentspräsidentin Pommer forderte
jeder einzelne müsse Aufstehen gegen
Hass auf Juden geflüchtete oder
Homosexuelle für die Überlebenden des
Holocausts ergriff im Landtag der
91-Jährige Naftali Fürst das Wort
Melanie Hag hat mit ihm
gesprochen was sagt ein Mensch der
Auschwitz und Buchenwald überlebt hat
als Kind der heute wieder in Thüringen
ist als Zeitzeuge was sagt dieser Mensch
gekommen aus Israel über die politische
Gegenwart am 7 Oktober
2023 wurde ich daran erinnert was
Todesangst
ist ich hatte keine Angst um mich
sondern um meine Enkelin Mika am 7
oktober wurden die Schwiegereltern
seiner Enkelin beim Angriff auf Israel
ermordet er hätte nie gedacht dass Juden
heute wieder verfolgt werden und dass
ich auch in Deutschland das politische
Klima dreht das ist für mich sehr
traurig und ich habe nicht geglaubt dass
noch nach 80 Jahre noch einmal die
Faschismus und Rassismus kommt
hinauf im Thüringer Landtag ist die AFD
stark während alle anderen im Saal
klatschen Stille bei den AFD Vertretern
der 91-Jährige Naftali Fürst sorgt sich
um die Zukunft nicht viele Sachen kann
mir Angst machen aber ich bin traurig
dass ist so etwas noch einmal passiert
die Leute was das machen die
AFD haben nichts gelernt von den was war
sagt einer der letzten Überlebenden der
reden will solange er kann man muss
Frieden machen auch in Israel auch in
Ukraina dass man darf nicht morden einen
ein anderen weil alle sind Menschen bald
müssen andere Menschen
übernehmen das Auswärtige Amt hat
offenbar eine großangelegte prorussische
Desinformationskampagne aufgedeckt nach
einem Bericht des Spiegels wurden
innerhalb eines Monats mehr als eine
Million Nachrichten über die Plattform x
abgesetzt darin wurde der
Bundesregierung etwa vorgeworfen sie
vernachlässige die eigene Bevölkerung um
der Ukraine zu helfen dafür wurden
50.000 gefälschte Nutzerkonten
eingerichtet verbreitet wurden auch
Links die zu gefälschten Internetseiten
führen die denen etablierter medienänder
äheln trotz Protesten ist in in USA
erstmals ein Mensch mit Stickstoff
hingerichtet worden der wegen Mordes
verurteilte Kenneth eugene Smith wurde
in einem Gefängnis im US-Bundesstaat
Alabama exekutiert die EU und das
menschenrechtsbüro der Vereinten
Nationen verurteilten die Methode als
grausam der 58-Jährige habe bei der
Hinrichtung eindeutig
gelitten nach Frankreich auch dort sind
die Landwirte unzufrieden und bringen
ihren Frust auf die Straße und und zwar
deutlich das ist das Bild von
Frankreichs Autobahnen heute Nachmittag
etliche Vollsperrungen ganz im Süden
sogar über eine Distanz von 400 km die
Bauern protestieren gegen sinkende
Einnahmen und gegen zu viele Vorgaben
Anne
Arend an ihnen kommt keiner vorbei
tausende Traktoren blockieren die Zuwege
nach Paris mit voller Kraft bringen
Frankreichs Bauern ihren Protest auf
dieut en Haren entschlossen
aus wir werden uns nicht mehr mit ein
paar Maßnahmen abspeisen lassen das ist
seit Jahren ein grundlegendes Problem
und unsere Politiker müssen sich
wirklich
bewegen Frankreich ist ein Agrarland mit
400.000 Bauern ein stolzer Berufsstand
dessen Wut die Regierung unter Druck
setzt eilig reist der neue Premier aufs
Land verspricht unter anderem
Bürokratieabbau finanzielle
Unterstützung der Biolandwirtschaft und
die Steuern für Agrardiesel nicht zu
erhöhen und dann richtet er seine Worte
an die Rechtspopulisten die den Bauern
Frust für ihre europafeindliche Agenda
nutzen wollen Europa unterstützt uns mit
Agrarsubventionen 9 Milliarden Euro im
Jahr für unsere Bauern aus der EU
auszusteigen würde bedeuten dass wir
dass sie auf 9 Milliarden Euro
verzichten müssten lässt sich der
Protest mit diesen Maßnahmen nun
besänftigen später am Abend wollen die
Bauernverbände eine Erklärung abgeben
die Blockaden bleiben vorerst noch
bestehen es ist offenbar für manche ein
gutes Geschäft wem wegen zu schnellen
Fahrens oder anderen Verkehrssünden
Punkte in flenzburg drohen der kann sich
freikaufen also die Strafpunkte gegen
Geld jemandem anderen übertragen und das
ist nicht mal verboten weil es da eine
Lücke im Gesetz gibt ein Thema auf dem
Verkehrsgerichtstag in gosla Fabian
Köhler berichtet Bußgelder im
Straßenverkehr teuer und häufig kommen
Punkte im Verkehrszentralregister dazu
acht Punkte und der Führerschein ist
erstmal weg im Netz Kanal zu jeder
Verkehrssünder seine Punkte gegen
Bezahlung loswerden ganz legal
Punktehandel ein Thema beim
Verkehrsgerichtstag vor allem Polizei
und Verkehrsverbände wollen die
Gesetzeslücke geschlossen wissen weil
sie bedenken müssen dass es sich bei
denjenigen die Interesse haben ihre
Punkte tatsächlich loszuwerden und dafür
Geld zu zahlen meistens um Menschen
handelt die schon häufiger in den
Konflikt geraten sind mit dem
Verkehrsrecht punktehändler arbeiten in
der Regel mit einer Kartei voller
Klienten zusammen sendet ein
Verkehrssünder seinen Anhörungsbogen
gleich der Anbieter seine Kartei ab
sucht einen passenden Strohmann
existiert ein Foto wird nach einer
ähnlichen Person gesucht dieser strohann
füllt den Anhörungsbogen mit seinen
Daten aus und sendet die Unterlagen an
die Behörde so übernimmt er die Strafe
und der Verkehrssünder ist reingewaschen
ist dieser Handel strafbar dies eine der
Kernfragen auf der Fachkonferenz die
Empfehlung an den Gesetzgeber lautet nun
zumindest gewerblicher Punktehandel
solle unterbunden werden unklar ist
allerdings ob die Gesetzgebung wirklich
verschärft
wird das ist die pittureske Altstadt von
Tartu in Estland Tartu steht ab heute im
Rampenlicht als europäische
Kulturhauptstadt das Motto dafür
überlebenskünste Begründung für ein
besseres Leben bräuchten wir mehr
Originalität mehr nach tigkeit und mehr
Einfallsreichtum dazu animieren ab heute
1000 Veranstaltungen im Sommer z.B ein
Massen küssen Natalie
Steger in der Nacht versprüht das
estnische Tartu den meisten Charm die
Eröffnungszeremonie am Abend alle
Menschen jung alt
lgbtqi sollen sich vertreten fühlen alle
knen uns als digitalisiertes Land aber
Digitalisierung hat auch Hintergründe
wir müssen Menschen bleiben wir müssen
menschliche Kontakte haben 100000
Einwohner Russland ist naher Nachbar es
gab gemeinsame Projekte nach dem
Überfall auf die Ukraine wurde alles
gestrichen eine Ausstellung Kunst und
Wissenschaft gehören in Tartu zusammen
die Stadt hat die wichtigste Universität
istlands Streetart ist typisch oft auf
Überresten der sjetbesatz
t eine outdooralerie das Motto
überlebenskünste perfekt für Tartu sagt
Künstlerin
[Musik]
Stina wenn du an Berlin denkst oder New
York da kannst du keine Ruhepause finden
zwischen deinen Projekten in so einer
cityumgebung aber in tu geht das es ist
zu
ruhig eine bunte Stadt und ziemlich
entspannt europäische Kultur Hauptstadt
2024 jetzt zum Sport viele haben ihm so
die Daumen gedrückt Alexander s im
Halbfinale der Australian Open hat aber
nichts genützt ja echt schade denn
anfangs war der Hamburger deutlich
besser als sein Gegner Daniel metvedev
SEV gewann die beiden ersten Sätze doch
dann wendete sich das Blatt in einem
über vierstündigen
tenniskremi so sehen im doppelten
Wortsinn glückliche Sieger aus denn der
Russe dan
ist gegen alexanderev nicht der bessere
aber der konstantere Spieler der
deutsche Olympiasieger beginnt stark und
gewinnt die ersten beiden Sätze
überlegen mit 7:5 und 6:3 doch dann
kippt das Spiel weil meded fort an die
entscheidenden Punkte macht und zum 2:2
nach setätzen ausgleicht im
entscheidenden Durchgang schenkt ZF
gerade zuu mit seiner heute aufffallen
schwachen Vorhand medw den Einzug
indessen bereits drittes Melbourner
Finale trotz dieser schmerzlichen
Niederlage kann ZF auf einen
vielversprechenden Start in das neue
Tennisjahr
zurückblicken Jürgen Klopp hört auf als
Trainer des FC Liverpool zum Saisonende
die Begründung des 56jährigen er habe
keine Energie mehr nach 9 Jahren an der
Enfield Road das Ende einer
Ehra Champions League Sieger englischer
Meister aktuell wieritze nun die
angekündigte
Trennung Tri dann besser etwas zu früh
als zu
spät der Zeitpunkt gewählt aus Respekt
vom Club Liverpool und klop viel mehr
als eine normale
Arbeitsbeziehung ich bin noch immer ein
normaler Typ habe nur schon zu lang kein
normales Leben ab dem Sommer will er
mindestens ein Jahr nicht als Trainer
arbeiten selbst ein Karriereende ist
nicht
ausgeschlossen Auftag der skiflug WM in
badmterndorf und da liegt Andreas
Wellinger nach zwe von vier durchgäng
auf Platz 4 und kann also noch auf eine
Medaille hoffen ja und beim Auftag der
rodelheim WM in Altenberg hat Max
langenhann im Sprint einsätzer Silber
geholt noch besser lief es für
toprodlerin Julia taubitz die 27jährige
siegte vor der Schweizerin Natalie Mark
und der Lettin Elena Jea witola für
taubitz das zweite sprintgold ihrer
Karriere erfolgreich auch das deutsche
skeleton Team in Lillehammer Hanna Neise
feierte ihren zweiten Weltcupsieg und
bei den Männern gab es sogar einen
Dreifacherfolg Olympiasieger Christopher
grotter gewann mit 800 Sekunden
Vorsprung vor seinem Teamkollegen Axel
jung Felix Seibel wurde
dritter hter Sport bei uns in ZDF morgen
ab 950 Uhr und jetzt gleich live
Handball EM Halbfinale Deutschland
Dänemark mach voran wir müssen nach
Hause daumrücken gleich geht's los nur
noch zum Wetter das wird am Wochenende
ruhig trocken und viele sonnig die
Details hat gleich Katja hornöffer das
heute journal mit Christian sieas in der
handballhalbzeitpause um kurz nach alles
Gute Ihnen ein schönes Wochenende und
bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend nach der eher
schwach ausgeprägten warmf brauste heute
die Kaltfront von tief Katrin über uns
hinweg das Wochenende steht dann unter
dem Zeichen von hocheno die Kaltfront
aber schmiegt sich noch ein bisschen an
den Alpenrand und so kann es dort heute
Nacht noch etwas Regen oder Schnee geben
sonst bleibt es trocken zum Teil wird es
auch klar und dann bildet sich Nebel
örtlich könnte es auch mal glatt sein
denn die Temperaturen sinken zumeist auf
+ 3 bis -4° an der Ostsee bleibt es mit
+ 4° milder und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 3 ° in den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen und 8° an der
Ostsee oder auch am Rhein nach etwas
Nebel am Morgen wird das morgen im
Südwesten ein Strahlen sonniger Tag über
den Norden allerdings ziehen noch
Wolkenfelder hinweg das sind die Reste
der Kaltfront bei einem Wind aus
westlichen Richtungen der Sonntag wird
dann noch deutlich sonniger anfänglich
stören vielleicht einige Nebelfelder in
den Flusstälern Süddeutschlands und es
wird einen Tick milder bei Temperaturen
von 5 bis 11° die neue Woche startet
ähnlich es wird allerdings von Tag zu
Tag von Westen etwas wolkiger ich
wünsche dir noch einen schönen Abend und
ein schönes Wochenende